this is kind of exciting today marks the
first day of Japan fully opening its
borders and ending its covid-19 travel
restrictions Japan also lifted a limit
on the number of arrivals and the
country will no longer require tourists
to be part of a tour group so let's
bring in senior travel advisor Peter
Greenberg to talk a little bit more
about this this is so timely because we
were just talking about my family that
you know maybe this year Japan will be
our big trip you know we do the one big
trip and so we were actually talking
about this
um so I'm so glad you're here once again
now that Japan is open for Taurus what
are the requirements to get into the
country
well you know for over two years it's
been slow going or no going to Japan
they were truly a pandemic isolated
country uh in June they finally started
to open the doors saying you could go if
you were part of a guided organized tour
group uh then in September they said you
could go without the guide but it had to
be a tour group now as of today anybody
can come uh you just need proof of
vaccination or a negative PCR test uh
and other than that it's open now what's
interesting about that is the numbers
between the beginning of this year and
now only about 500 000 people have
visited Japan mostly since June compared
to 32 million that went back in 2019 so
I'll give you an idea of why this is a
big big news day for Japan yeah
definitely
um when's the best time to fly to Japan
then and what factors should should
Travelers be considering
well I'm going to give you a qualified
answer it would be now because there's
nobody there right
but the qualification is this uh they're
having the same issues with with supply
chain problems and staff shortages that
we are 73 of all hotels in Japan are
recording staff shortages so be aware of
that keep in mind you're going to be
wearing masks on the planes going there
on many of the Japanese Airlines and in
public places throughout the country
other than that uh the good news is the
yen is at a 25-year low against the U.S
dollar much like the power of the dollar
against the Euro or the British pound so
it's a buyer's market once you get there
really quickly Travelers often have the
option to buy insurance you know Japan
is a pretty expensive trip so for those
traveling to Japan specifically what
options are available to them when it
comes to insurance
well there are some new insurance
project products that will actually
protect you and cover you if you test
positive for covet other than that do
yourself a favor have a conversation
with a trip advisor or a travel agent to
find out exactly what the policy
excludes before you buy it at all
because in many cases there's still
exclusions there that make your policy
meaningless if you don't do the right
homework all right Peter thank you very
much I'll just have a conversation with
Peter and get all the tips that I need
thank you very much